voilà la voyons nous
bien nino mon invité adrien pas de
sourire pendant générer des amis contre
8 mai non non non il ya un petit
restaurant côté du studio contraire
bonsoir ce soir on improvise avec des
jeunes comédiens qui sont à la fois
auteur metteur en scène a bien et qu'ils
auront plus de spectateurs durant en dix
minutes que molière durant toute cette
m'ont invité adrian bebb boy george
temps philippe va tirer un premier sujet
d'une main innocente
parenti
milano nous avons la même part
jeune comédienne deux films
pornographiques sont rentrés à la
comédie française au yassiri quelqu'un
les madmoizelles avait le physique de
l'emploi partenaires oui je n'ai pas
besoin d'accessoires
non on a changé un peu le sujet s'est
pas fait
bonjour maintenant affair dentier
bonjour monsieur longuet bonjour le club
entier bonjour monsieur janvier bonjour
le plantier bonjour ma section biennoise
avez-vous ça va nay avant et pourquoi
mon mari a passé trois jours dans le
coma
ah bon et il a eu beau temps
la comédie française ne sort pas grandie
c'est un terme
c'est vraiment improvisée dans un moment
de bonne compagnie kinh ce qui merci
d'avoir partagé avec nous cet apéritif
de souris bonsoir à demain